what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and asta just got
issacied to a place with strange magical
powers a place where yami's childhood
friend is about to teach him a brand new
up at least that's what he claims but
the reality could be a lot more sinister
as i'm going to discuss in this video
whoever he really is the guy who claims
to be ami's friend has truly
unbelievable magic that could be related
to time so let's break it all down right
now you guys know how this works if you
like our black lower videos you want us
to keep it going with the black lore
videos leave a quick like and comment
right now it only takes you a second but
it really helps us with that youtube
algorithm and of course subscribing and
hitting that notification bell is a
completely free way of supporting the
channel right now subscribing might seem
like a little thing but it actually
helps us out a ton on youtube finally
this video will of course contain black
clover manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned okay
so in the previous chapter we of course
saw that asta was magically teleported
to a mysterious beach where a certain
person was already expecting him that in
itself was a huge mystery because no one
was planning for asta to appear there
and no one even knew where osta ended up
after he was hit with that spatial magic
spell our only clue about asta's
whereabouts was the outfit of the man
who was standing over him on the beach
and that's because the outfit looked
like traditional japanese attire since
we know that yami is originally from
hino country a land that strongly
resembles medieval japan from our own
world many of us guessed that asta might
have somehow ended up in yami's homeland
and this hypothesis was indeed confirmed
in the latest chapter but then even
stranger things began to happen things
that are about to have a massive impact
on the rest of the story oh and did i
say that it was confirmed that asta was
in yami's homeland well
maybe not so fast the latest chapter
starts off at the home base of the black
bulls where all the black bulls who were
not in the capital are now gathered as
they engage in their usual shenanigans
noct arrives and tells them that asta is
most likely dead as the black bulls look
on in disbelief nocht explains that asta
was clearly mortally wounded by lucius
and he was then erased by spatial magic
if we take all of that into
consideration the most logical and
reasonable conclusion is that asta is
dead knocked is like listen i know this
makes you feel terrible but facts are
facts and facts don't care about your
feelings nevertheless on the very next
page noct says that even though
objectively speaking asta being dead is
the most likely scenario knocked still
doesn't believe that asta is dead and he
won't believe it unless he sees osta's
dead body with his own eyes all the
black bulls instantly agree with knocked
there is no way that asta is dead
because asta never gives up and so they
will never give up on asta and also this
is black clover so hostas obviously not
dead guys anyway knocked then declares
that the decision is unanimous and he
invites everyone to head out and find
that idiot hosta as soon as possible the
next page shows asta himself waking up
inside what looks to be a traditional
japanese room from like the edo period
he is wondering where he is when a
little girl that looks like a japanese
charmy suddenly comes into the room this
charmy turns out to be some sort of
automaton that vomits tea from its mouth
and then serves it to people that is
definitely not off-putting at all some
of the finest tea in the world is
actually robot vomit that is a fact and
so as asta looks on in confusion a man
dressed in traditional japanese clothing
explains that this is a tea serving doll
we then see the man's face and it
appears to be the same man who had been
expecting asta on the beach back when he
was first isekai now that we see this
man it's clear that he looks a lot like
yami although his hairstyle is different
and he also wears an eye patch but other
than that he could easily be yami's
brother asta is surprised that this
random guy knows his name but he is even
more surprised when he realizes that his
mortal wound looks like it has been
completely healed asta believes that
only mimosas overpowered shenron magic
could heal a wound that severe and he
asks this man if he was the one who
healed him the man replies that no he
doesn't have that kind of power but his
friend does there is a third person
there in the room with them a serious
and dignified young woman who is also
wearing traditional japanese clothing
but i'm not sure if this is the healing
friend that the man is referring to or
if he's talking about a different friend
either way the man seems to have a lot
of friends who are skilled healers
because he also explains that liebe is
currently being fixed up by more of his
friends the man also seems to be fully
aware of devils and their existence and
asta is extremely curious to know who
this mysterious man is
the only thing that asta knows about him
is that his key
isn't hostile the man then explains that
he has known yami since childhood and
asta confirms that their key is similar
the man claims that he grew up with yami
but he hasn't seen his friend since he
disappeared at age 13. the man even asks
asta whether yami still takes long dumps
which basically confirms that he really
does know yami quite well the man then
proceeds to describe other aspects of
yami's personality including his mean
look his aggressive nature and his fear
of bugs and as the man is talking the
girl beside him seems to be like mean
mugging him as if she doesn't want him
to joke around about yami i wonder if
she has some connection to yami like
maybe she is his sister or something
asta thanks the man for his help but he
explains that he has to rush back to his
friends because the clover kingdom is in
danger the man responds by saying that
asta cannot go back now because if he
does he will lose the man also knows
that asta just had his heart broken by
the woman he loved and then both that
woman and the person he looked up to the
wizard king tried to kill him when asta
asks how this man could possibly know
all these things the man taps his eye
patch and says that he has the power to
see whatever he wants to and it is this
eye that is telling him that asta isn't
strong enough to defeat his enemy at
least not yet and besides even if foster
wanted to go back to the clover kingdom
right away it simply isn't within his
power to go back that's because he is
now in hino country which is very far
from the clover kingdom
at the very least it is on another
continent but we still don't know for
sure if this is a different part of the
black clover world or a different
dimension altogether
the man then finally introduces himself
as ryudo ryuja the shogun of hino
country also known as the land of the
sun and he says that he can give asta a
much needed power up
and that is how this absolutely insane
chapter ends we just got some intense
world building a new completely
overpowered character was casually
introduced and asta is confirmed to be
receiving a major power up very soon
this is definitely an exciting time for
all of us in the black clover fandom and
here is my main takeaway from the events
of this chapter the first thing that got
my attention is the seemingly completely
broken magic of ryuya's eye how does he
know asta's name how does he know what
exactly happened to asta before he
arrived here how did he know that asta
would be isakai to that specific
location at that specific time how does
he know that asta would lose if he
returned to the clover kingdom now
either ryuya has a magic power that is
equivalent to some sort of magical
psychic power like mind reading or
precognition or something along those
lines or he might have a power related
to time magic if ryuja could peak into
the future like say lucius can then he
could probably see future scenarios that
allowed him to know all of this
information but could that mean that
ryuya also has a fragment of asteroth's
time magic or does he have some
completely different type of magic power
whatever is going on here it's clear
that ryuuya is extremely powerful to the
point of being broken and that is before
we even get into the crazy overpowered
healing powers that the ruya's allies
seem to have and is ryuia's magic the
thing that brought asta to hino country
before he could be killed by sister lily
and lucius and if so how freaking
powerful is this man that t doll
automaton also caught my eye because
although it serves just a basic function
like serving tea this could be our first
hint that yami's homeland is actually
more technologically advanced than the
clover kingdom and that could end up
playing some role in the story i mean i
don't think that technology alone will
be super important in what is clearly a
fantasy series but perhaps hino country
possesses some sort of advanced magical
technology that might give asta an edge
in the final battle and speaking of
hosta and the final battle what kind of
power up do you think that asta is about
to receive from ryuya is there some sort
of secret samurai magic that the clover
kingdom simply isn't aware of perhaps a
magical power-up that requires the
mastery of ki
which is something that the majority of
the clover kingdom residents are not
familiar with at all or are we talking
about something else here like hino
country having their own unique demons
slash devils or maybe even kami slash
gods who could allow asta to achieve a
power up now to be clear it's very
likely that ryuya really was telling the
truth and that he is going to be asta's
new ally and mentor but there is one
other intriguing possibility that's not
nearly as likely but that i just
couldn't get out of my mind after seeing
that girl's face while ryuja was talking
about yami what if ryuya has some sort
of illusion magic and everything asta is
seeing is actually a lie what if yuya is
working with lucius or as perhaps even
lucius in disguise and this girl beside
him is either sister lily or some other
accomplice who may have mixed feelings
about what's going on i say this because
a dark twist like that would explain a
lot lucy has seemed very confident that
asta has been eliminated as a threat and
it could be because he transferred him
somewhere where he would be mentally
trapped in an illusion and wouldn't be
able to get out maybe lucius even plans
on doing some experiments on anti-magic
while asta is trapped in this illusion
someone who could mess with asta's mind
would be able to extract all the
information that ruya knew about asta
including the yami stuff and since hasta
knows that yami is from a mysterious
land on another continent ryuya could
just make that construct and make
himself look like yami in order to make
asta trust him this may also explain why
liebe was not there with asta which to
me was very suspicious right away austin
liebe are practically inseparable and
now they've suddenly been separated
while asta is unconscious and of course
this would explain why ryuya found asta
at exactly the right place at exactly
the right time asta fell into the very
trap that ryuya had set for him for the
start finally the black bulls setting
off to find asta means that they will
have to defeat ryuya or whoever he
really is and force him to release
asta in the process of this internal
struggle asta may just unlock the kind
of power up that he needs to defeat
lucius
again this is not a likely scenario asta
most likely is in hino country and if
this illusion scenario were true then we
would also have to explain away the fact
that ryuya's ki was not threatening to
asta basically ryuuya would have to
manipulate not only asta's mind but also
his key sensing ability in order for
this part to work so yeah yuya probably
is telling the truth but it would be
pretty freaking dark if it turned out
that asta was trapped inside an illusion
within his own mind while on the outside
he might actually still be dying from
that deadly wound let me know what you
guys think do you trust ryuya and what
is his magic power how does his
mysterious eye actually function and
what other abilities do you think he has
who was that girl that was with ryuia
and does she have some connection to
yami finally was ryuia able to somehow
manipulate sister lily's spell in order
to teleport asta to that exact location
or did something else happen here drop
me a line down in the comments i always
love hearing from you you guys know the
drill if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment right now it
helps me out a lot and if you're new to
the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications i know it might not
seem like a big deal but subscribing and
hitting that bell here on youtube means
a lot and of course it's completely free
you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram at
animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime outpour patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including alpha sigma pate
heffa the toasted qi corey mcgowan big
buddhist and jeremy pontier and i can't
forget all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz alicia octor fat boy games
kaido might be a duck alivania and anime
s codem if you guys enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon or
here through youtube memberships even a
single dollar helps and it means a lot
to us as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys